hi a question I get asked all the time
is how is it possible do you speak so
many languages and you don't confuse
them well first and foremost I would say
that I do actually confuse languages it
happens but it happens in very specific
circumstances but the reason why this
doesn't happen very often is first and
foremost because I develop a specific
side of my personality with these
languages when it comes to learning a
language you don't just learn words you
don't just learn sounds you learn and
you acquire another way of being in this
world and that really makes a difference
if you learn how to develop a certain
side of your personality with the
language and through the language that
you learn then it's like being you know
when you're like on the radio and you
just change the frequency once you are
in that frequency that frequency and the
sounds that you hear they're not they
have nothing to do with another
frequency that's exactly how it works
for me when it comes to a language
learning when they speak English
American English in this case I am on
that frequency and nothing else can
disturb that state of mind the reason
why that happens is because I have
developed a sign of my personality
through American English you will notice
that if you speak a different language
another language apart from not from
your own native language you will notice
that your hand gestures your facial
features your expressions they change
with the language and through the
language that you're speaking then
that's because you have developed a
certain personality that is you are the
result of the society you live in you
are the result of your the result of
episodes of people you hang around of
things and experiences that you've had
so that is literally shaping one side of
your personality so the tip here the
thing to keep in mind is that if you
want to learn not to confuse languages
if you want to learn a bunch of
languages not confused you have to
develop together with sounds together
with minerals you have to develop
another side of your personality it's
about when you when it comes to language
learning it's not about having other
languages under your
it's about being richer being more than
you would be only with one language that
is one thing I fortunately or
unfortunately there are some other
things that depend strictly on
circumstances for example what is
happening right now with me is that my
polish is getting stronger in terms of
in terms of retrieval than a Russian
Russian is stronger in terms of storage
there's this amazing book which is here
so it's called the surprising truth
about how we learn by Benedict Kari and
the author talks about the fact that and
disciplines to language learning as well
you have a capacity of retrieval and
capacity of storage meaning that for
example we store things and then our
capacity of retrieving these things
these pieces of information from memory
depends basically on use so my Russian
is without a doubt stronger in terms of
storage information than my polish but
right now I'm using polish so much for
personal reasons every day that every
time that I want to say something in
Russian polish takes over so to say so
in order to avoid that what you should
do and the reason why actually this is
happening is because I'm using Polish so
much more than the Russian these days
but there is a very easy remedy to that
and the easiest remedy is just to use
both languages at the same time even if
you use one every day for your life
circumstances make you make sure that
you don't forget the other one if I
dedicate or started dedicating 20-30
minutes of Russian everyday the
situation would would get better in no
time
another situation that I've seen and
that happens quite a lot maybe it
happened to you as well is that you
learn a language well because maybe you
spent some time and if in in a country
let's suppose that you're an American
who lived in Spain for three years
learned Spanish to fluency and then all
of a sudden you go and move to another
country
in which people speak a language that is
similar to the one you learnt for
example say a tie and you move to
beautiful Italy and you start speaking
Italian every day then it will happen
again that every time that you want to
speak Spanish Italian will come to the
fore so to say and that happens because
of the retrieval and storage problem
that we have once again easy solution is
just to try to use both if you're in
Italy you will obviously learn and speak
Italian much more so you can actually
organize your time so that you you
actually spend time speaking Spanish
with friends in a bar or reading or
whatever it is the secret is simple just
do a little bit of both languages or
three languages or more every single day
obviously this problem gets bigger and
bigger the more languages you speak so
in order at let's let's recap the first
thing the reason why as a polyglot we're
a hyperpolyglot wherever you want to
call me I don't have I don't struggle
that much with confusing languages is
because I have developed a certain
personality that is not just a result of
the books that I've read or the the
grammar rules that I've started or the
sounds that I have acquired but it's an
overall experience of being richer
because I've integrated faces
experiences colors emotions together
with sounds and grammar rules and words
and the second thing is that there are
some conflicts and sometimes you can
confuse languages due to life
circumstances you you know it's never
always the same thing when it comes to
languages because you're suitable life
situation changes so in that case make
sure that if you're using one language
more than the other just make sure that
you start using somehow passively and/or
actively the other language that is
being less dominant in that precise
moment otherwise you will run the risk
of having some kind of conflict
confusion or one language only one
language will come instead of the other
once again thanks for watching and I
see you in the next video bye